it's a product accent made of vibranium
it's stronger than steel and a third the
way it's completely vibration absorbent
how come it's not standard issue that's
the rarest metal on earth what you're
holding there that's all we've got
you're quite finished with the stock hey
how's it going everyone it's Warren and
we know by now that Tony Stark will
indeed be getting a new Iron Man suit in
Avengers endgame several months after
Avengers infinity war came out we began
to get some leaks for Avengers in-game
or what we would call Avengers 4 at the
time and included in those leaks was a
new Iron Man armor that we have never
seen before called the mark 85 as we got
more and more leaks for this armor it
was very clear that it was modeled after
the original Iron Man armor from the
comics with the classic red and gold so
what exactly is new about this new armor
and can it top the mark 50 that we saw
Iron Man wear in Avengers infinity war
with nanotechnology
we'll talk about it in this video and
just a reminder about my giveaway if
you'd like to enter for your chance to
win 5 imax tickets to see Avengers in
game or Captain Marvel and imax all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
with the notifications turned on like
the video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain so it seemed like
in Avengers infinity war that the mark
50 with nanotechnology Iron Man suit
would be the best and most
technologically advanced Iron Man suit
that we'd ever see but now we know that
he's getting a new one thanks to some
leaks and official promo art photos that
Marvel have released themselves but
what's really interesting about Iron Man
getting new armor into endgame is that
the Russo brothers have already came out
and said that Iron Man has reached a
peak with nanotechnology this is the
most advanced and literal best suit that
Tony Stark could make so if
nanotechnology is the best that he could
do technologically and he can't upgrade
it how does he make the suit better he
could upgrade what the nano bytes are
made out of because somebody else has a
nanotech suit that is made out of much
stronger material than what I earn man's
mark 50 is made out of and that is of
course black panther Black Panthers
entire suit is laced with vibranium the
strongest material on earth and his suit
is nano
technology so it is possible that
Ironman could make a vibranium
nanotechnology suit in fact it's
probably the only way that he could
upgrade his suit because remember the
Russa brother said this is it for Tony
Stark it's the most technologically
advanced suit that he could make so he
can't upgrade the tech but he can't
upgrade what it's made out of Tony
obviously knows about vibranium because
of his father and because of Captain
America's shield and not to mention
Ultron the most versatile substance on
the planet and they used it to make a
frisbee typical of humans they scratch
the surface and everything but the
problem is and why Ironman never made a
vibranium suit before is because all of
the vibranium is in Wakanda and they
never let anybody have any all of the
vibranium that existed outside of
Wakanda was smuggled out but now that
half of the universe has been wiped away
from existence the earth will have to
unite and obviously Wakanda knows who
they know says they fought against his
army in infinity war and we learned from
Black Panther and infinity war that what
Conda has technology that nobody else in
the world has and we know from an
interview with Robert Downey jr. that
Iron Man will be in Wakanda at some
point so since Tony Stark will be in
Wakanda the most technologically
advanced place on the earth and we know
that he gets a new suit it would make
sense that he builds it at Wakanda and
uses vibranium since he now has access
to it this is something that Tony has
probably wanted to do for a really long
time but just never had access to
vibranium even after meeting two chala
in civil war while Conda has always been
super strict about letting any vibranium
out but again now that after half of the
planet's population has been wiped away
from existence including the wakandan
king black panther the world needs to
come together to do anything they can to
undo the snap and defeat Thanos and
again we know from an interview with
Robert Downey jr. that Iron Man will be
in Wakanda at some point and since we
know he gets a suit upgrade but we know
that nanotechnology was the best that he
could do it makes sense that he would
upgrade it by making it out of vibranium
and not to mention in some of the leaks
that we've gotten it does look like the
suit is made out of vibranium so let me
know what you think about Tony Stark
making a vibranium Iron Man suit in
Avengers
endgame leave your thoughts in the
comments down below and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like the video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
Avengers endgame as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]